The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I thought I'd
begin today with,
as we're coming to the
end of the sort of focus
on linear algebra and moving
on to a little probability,
a little more optimization,
and a lot of deep learning.
So this was like,
by way of review,
to write down the big
factorizations of a matrix.
And so my idea, and
I kind of enjoyed it,
is checking that the
number of free parameters,
say an L and U or a Q
and R or every-- each
of those, that the
number of free parameters
agrees with the number of
parameters in A itself,
like n squared, usually.
So A usually has n squared.
And then can we replace A if--
after we've computed L and U,
can we throw away A?
Yes, because all the
information is in L and U.
And it fills that
same n by n matrix.
Well, that's kind of obvious
because L is lower triangular,
and the diagonal, all ones,
are not free parameters.
And U is triangular,
upper triangular.
And it's diagonal to the pivots.
Those are free
parameters so that--
but can I just write
down the count?
So I'll go through each
of these just quickly
after I've figured out how--
these are sort of the building
blocks.
So how many free parameters are
there in these two triangular
matrices?
Well, I think the answer
is 1/2 n, n minus 1,
and 1/2 n, n plus 1.
That's a familiar number.
You recognize that as the
sum of 1 plus 2, up to n.
And you have one free para--
in the upper
triangular U. You've
got one free parameter up in
the corner, two in the next one.
And as you're coming
down, you end up
with n on the main diagonal.
And they add up to that.
And you see that those
two are different by n,
which is what we want.
OK.
Diagonal.
The answer is obviously n.
How about the
eigenvector matrix?
This whole exercise
is like something
I've never seen in a textbook.
But for me it brings
back all these key--
really the condensed
course in linear algebra
is on that top line.
So how many free parameters
in an eigenvector matrix?
OK.
And of course, if
you're sort of thinking,
what's the rule for
free parameters?
My answer is going to be, for
the number of free parameters,
so this is an n by n matrix
with the n eigenvectors in it.
But there's a certain
freedom there.
And what is that?
What freedom do we have in
choosing the eigenvector
matrix?
Every eigenvector can be
multiplied by a scalar.
If x is an
eigenvector, so is 2x.
So is 3x.
So we could make a convention
that the first component
was always 1.
Maybe that wouldn't be the
most intelligent convention
in the world.
But it would show that
that top row of ones
were not to be counted.
So I get n squared
minus n for that.
Oh, yeah.
Well, having done those two,
let me look at this one.
Does that come out a
total of n squared?
Yes, because the
eigenvector x has n
squared minus n by this
reasoning, little hokey
reasoning that I just gave.
And then there are n more
for the eigenvalue matrix.
And there's nothing
left for the eigen--
the inverse because
it's determined by x.
So do you see the count adding
up to n squared for those?
Now, I left open
the orthogonal one.
I think we kind of talked
about that during the--
when we met it.
And it's a little less obvious.
But do you remember?
So I'm talking about an n by
n orthogonal matrix, Q. So
how many free parameters
in column one?
That column is what
we always call Q1.
Does it have n free parameters?
Or is there a condition
that cuts that back?
There is a condition, right?
And what's the condition
on the first column
that removes one parameter?
It's normalized.
Its length is 1.
So I only get n minus 1
from the first column.
And now if I move over
to the second column,
how many free parameters there?
Again, it's a unit vector.
But also, it is
orthogonal to the first.
So two parameters got you--
two rules got imposed.
And two parameters got removed.
So this is n minus 2.
And then finally, whatever.
So I think that that--
sum of these guys is exactly
the same that we had up here.
I think it's also 1/2 n, n minus
1, or 1/2n squared minus n.
Yeah.
Yeah, so not as
many as you might
think because the matrix
is size n squared.
Now, can I use those?
Because these are the--
like the building blocks.
Can I just check these?
Let's see.
I'll just go along the list.
L times U. So L had this.
And U had that.
And when I add those,
it adds up to n squared.
Right?
The minus cancels the plus.
And the 1/2n squared
twice gives me n squared.
So good for that one.
What about QR?
Well, R is upper
triangular like so.
And then Q, we just
got it right there.
So for Q times R, it's that
plus that again, adding to n
squared.
Good for that one.
n squared for that one.
And this one we just did.
n squared minus n in x.
n on the diagonal.
Total n squared.
What about this guy?
What about the big,
really fundamental one
that I would normally write
to matrix as S instead of A
to remind us that it--
that the matrix
here is symmetric?
So I'm not expecting n
squared for a symmetric ma--
oh, I should've put
that on my list.
What's the count for
a symmetric matrix?
Because this is an S here.
So I'm not expecting
to get n squared.
I'm only expecting to get
the number of symmetric S.
What's the number of free
parameters that I would--
that I start with that I hope
will reappear in Q and lambda?
What's the deal for
a symmetric matrix?
Let's see.
I'm free to choose.
Is it the same count as this?
Yeah, because I'm free to
choose the upper triangular
part and the diagonal, but I'm
not free to choose the lower.
So I'd say that's
1/2n times n minus 1.
And plus 1.
Sorry.
The diagonal's in there.
OK.
So do I get that total,
1/2 of n squared plus n,
from these guys?
Well, I probably do.
The diagonal guy gives me n.
This gives me n.
And that's a Q, which is my
other favorite number there.
And when I add that to that,
that becomes a plus sign.
And I'm good.
Yeah.
You see how I enjoy
doing this, right?
But I'm near the end.
But the last one is
kind of not well known.
OK.
Q times S. Do you remember
that factorization?
That's called the
polar decomposition.
It's an orthogonal
times the symmetric.
And it is often used
in engineering as a way
to decompose a
displacement, strain matrix.
Anyway, Q times S. And it--
actually, it's very,
very close to the SVD.
And I have friends
who say, better
to compute QS than the SVD
and then just move along.
Anyway, Q times S.
So Q is this guy.
And S. What's S?
Symmetric.
That's this guy.
So that's Q. Let me
write that letter Q and S
so I don't lose it.
What do those add up to?
N squared.
Happy.
OK.
So finally, the SVD.
Finally, the SVD.
What's the count?
Now I've got rectangular
stuff in there.
I'm ready for this one.
And I have to
think a little bit.
And we may have done this.
Let's suppose that m
is less or equal n.
Suppose that.
Yeah.
Otherwise, we would just
transpose and look at SVD.
So let's say m less or equal n.
So let's say it's got full rank.
And what's the largest rank
that the matrix can have?
m, clearly.
Full rank m.
So the SVD will be m by m.
Let's remember the U, the
sigma, and the V transpose.
This will be m by n.
And this will be n by n.
For the full scale SVD.
And if the rank is equal to m,
then I really expect to get--
I expect it to add
up to the total
for A. For A, the
original A has mn, right?
It's an m by n matrix.
The matrix A is m by n with the
m less or equal n, giving me
these things.
So it has mn parameters.
So do we get m
times n from this?
I hope we do.
I know how many
we get from sigma.
What?
How many was the
count for sigma?
m.
And what's the count for V?
So that's an n by n.
And what's the count for U?
OK.
Yeah.
They're orthogonal matrices.
So I should be able
to go up to that line.
This was an m by n one.
Is that a 1/2n, n minus 1?
Am I copying that correctly
out of this circle there?
That's an m by m
orthogonal matrix.
Oh, but I have to write m.
That was foolish.
OK. m.
m.
Yeah, because that
matrix is of size m.
So that's an m.
And then I have that.
And then I have whatever
V transpose n by n.
Oh, what's the deal in there?
Hmm.
Do I want all of
the 1/2n, n minus 1?
Oh, God.
I thought I had
got this straight.
Let's see.
I could subtract this from this
and find out what I should say.
Whoa.
Students have been
known to do this too.
Let's see.
Well, let's try to think anyway.
So I have this n by n symmet--
this n by n orthogonal matrix.
First, it could be
any orthogonal matrix.
Yeah.
But is it only the first m
columns that I really need?
The rest I could
just throw away.
Let me try to imagine
that it's just the first.
Well, then I won't
have any n in here.
So maybe I better take a 1/2n--
no.
Help.
Oh, oh, yes, of course.
Ha.
I've got only m columns
that matter, the--
everybody sort of now
understands that SVD.
The rank is m.
Don't forget that.
OK.
Then the first R, the first
m columns of V are important.
Those are the singular vectors
that go with nonzero singular
values that really matter.
And the rest really
don't matter.
So I'm going to just--
I have to count how many--
so, sorry.
V, the important part of V
has how many on the m columns.
But it's an n by n matrix.
And those columns
are orthogonal.
So the answer is
not mn for this guy.
I have to go through this
foolish reasoning again.
I have n minus 1, plus n minus
2, plus so on, plus n minus m.
There were n minus
1 parameters in
the first orthogonal vector--
unit vector, n minus 2 in
the second one, up to n minus
m in the third.
And then V has some
more columns that
are coming, really, from a null
space, that are not important.
I believe this is the
right thing to do.
I'm hoping you agree.
And I mean, I'm hoping even more
that those add up to m times n.
OK.
I have a 1/2n s--
oh, I really have
to total this thing.
OK.
This had m terms.
So there's m of these n's.
And then I have to subtract
off 1 plus 2 plus 3, up to m.
And so what am I
subtracting off?
What's that sum?
1 plus 2 plus 3, stopping at m?
It's one of these guys, 1/2--
is it 1/2m, m plus 1?
Yeah, 1/2m, m plus 1.
Sorry.
1/2m, m plus 1.
I'm supposed to enjoy this.
And now it gets
a little nervous.
But OK.
So I believe that that is that.
OK.
Well, we have the mn.
That's a good sign that
we're shooting for.
So does the rest of
it add to nothing?
Well, I guess, yeah,
I guess it does.
When I put these two together,
I have 1/2m, m plus 1.
And then I'm subtracting
it away again.
So I get mn.
Hooray.
Well, it had to happen,
or we wouldn't--
anything-- before I erase
that board and consign
that to history, is there--
should I pause a little more?
Minute?
This will be, like, I'm
hoping, a one-page appendix
to the notes and the book.
And you'll see it.
But I do have one
more count to do.
And then I'm good
with this review
and ready to move onward to
the topic of saddle points
and ready to move
onward after that.
Well, I'll say a little bit
about the next lab homework
that I'm creating.
And then our next topic will
be, like, covariance matrices,
a little statistics this week.
Then we get a week off
we could-- to digest it.
And then come back for gradient
descent, and deep learning,
and those things.
OK.
Everybody happy with that?
So what's my final question?
My final question is the SVD
for any matrix of rank R.
So it's an m by n matrix.
But the rank is only R.
It's a natural question--
how many parameters are
there in a rank R matrix?
We may even have touched
on this question.
And I have two
ways to answer it.
And one way is the SVD.
And that will be similar to
what I just pushed up there.
So if the rank is R, the SVD
of this typical rank R matrix
will be U sigma V transpose.
But U, now this is the--
like the condensed thing,
where I've thrown away
stuff that's automatically zero
because if the rank is only R,
like if the rank was 1,
suppose the rank was 1,
then I'd have 1 column times
1 sigma times 1 row, right?
And I could do that
count for R equal 1.
Now I have R columns.
So this is m by R. Then
sigma is diagonal, of course.
So I'm going to get R
numbers out of that.
And this one is now R by n.
In other words, maybe I should,
like, save this little bit here
that was helpful.
But now I've got
m is reduced to R.
So I believe that if
I count these three,
I'll get the right number of
parameters for a rank R matrix.
And that's not so obvious
because the rank R matrices
are not a--
we don't have a subspace.
If I add a rank R matrix
to another rank R matrix,
well, the rank could be as big
as 2R and probably will be.
You know, it's just
a little interesting
to get your hands on
matrices of rank R
because they're kind of a
thin, like a, well, a mass--
person would call it a
manifold, some kind of a surface
within matrix space.
Have you ever thought
about matrix space?
So that's vector space
because we can add matrices.
We can multiply
them by constants.
We can take linear combinations.
We could call them
vectors if we like.
There would be a vector
space of m by n matrices.
What would be the
dimension of that space?
So the vector space of
all 3 by 4 matrices.
That has what dimension?
12.
12, because you've got
12 numbers to choose.
And it is a space
because you can add.
Now if I say 3 by 4
matrices of rank 2,
I don't have a space anymore.
That word, space, is
seriously preserved
for meaning vector
space, meaning
I can take combinations.
But if I take a rank 2 matrix
plus a rank 2 matrix, I'm not--
so it's sort of a surface
within 12d, the 2--
the 3 by 4 matrices of rank 2.
And we're about to find the
dimension of that surface.
Does your mind sort of visualize
a surface in 12 dimensions?
Yeah, well, give
it a shot anyway.
But that surface could have--
be 11 dimensional, so to speak,
like, meaning locally, the--
it wouldn't have to be a pl--
an 11 dimensional plane
going through the origin.
In fact, it wouldn't
go through the origin
because the origin
won't have rank R.
So it's some kind of a surface.
And maybe it's got
some different pieces.
Probably, some
smart person knows
what that surface looks like.
But we're just going
to find out something
about its number of parameters,
its local dimension.
Well, I know that this answer
is R because I've got R sigmas.
And this one, I'm
pretty good at.
But now it's not--
it's R by n, so it's--
instead of-- here R was m.
But now, down here, R is R.
So I think it's rn minus 1/2.
What's that?
Is that an m?
So now it's an r.
r plus 1.
I think.
And what about the U?
So U is going to be similar,
except instead of the n here,
we've got an m.
So I think for you, we'll have m
minus 1, plus m minus 2, plus--
so let me write it here.
m minus 1.
So U, I'm talking about U
here, it's got R columns.
The first one has m minus
1 because I throw away 1
because it's a unit
vector, up to m minus r.
That's r's column.
OK.
And now so how-- what
does that add up to?
Well, I put all
the m's together.
So that's rm, or let me say mr.
And then I'm subtracting on 1
plus 2 plus 3, up to r.
Now tell me again
what that adds up to.
1 plus 2 plus 3, stop at r.
That's what we had here.
And we've got it for V. And
we've got it again here.
Minus 1/2 r, r plus 1.
Are you OK with that?
And now I just want
to add them up.
So I have mr. And I have nr.
And then I have two of these.
So let me get it here.
mr and nr.
And now I have to look
at-- so mr, check.
nr, check.
Now I have two of these guys.
So they combine into
r squared plus r.
And then I-- r squared,
yeah, minus r squared plus r.
Sorry.
They combine into
minus r squared plus r.
And then here's r
coming in with a plus.
I think we have a
minus r squared.
And that is the right answer.
Yeah.
OK.
So I took a bit longer
than I intended.
But this is a number
that's sort of interesting.
I mentioned saddle points
sort of, like, separately
from maxima and minima just
because they are definitely not
as easy to work with.
You understand what I
mean by saddle points?
The matrices involved have--
are not positive definite.
Those would go with a maximum.
They're not negati--
they're not--
well, those would go
with maxima and minima.
But we're looking in between.
So saddle points.
OK.
Well, I'll get going on those.
I sort of realized that
there are two main sources
of saddle points.
One of them is when I
have problems that--
when I-- let's say I minimize.
So this will be the constraint.
The saddle points have
come from the constraint.
So Lagrange is going
to be responsible
for these saddle points.
So we might have some minimum
problem like minimize,
some positive definite thing.
And of course, if we don't say
anymore, the minimum is zero.
Right?
Because otherwise,
it's positive.
But we're going to put on
constraints, Ax equal b.
So this is the classical
constrained optimization
problem, quadratic cost
function, linear constraints.
We could solve this exactly.
But let's just see where saddle
points is going to arise.
So this S is positive definite.
But now how do we deal
with that problem?
Well, Lagrange said what to do.
Lagrange said, look
at the Lagrangium.
Well, OK.
He introduced lambda.
This x is in n dimensions.
That's an n by n matrix.
But I have m constraints.
So the matrix A is m by n.
I've m constraints.
And then I'm going to follow
the rules and introduce m,
Lagrange multipliers.
That's an m.
And then the neat
part of the Legra--
and what?
What is this?
Well, it's-- I
take the function,
and then I introduce--
remember, lambda's a vector
now, not just a number.
We had some application
where it was just--
there was just one constraint.
But now I have m constraints.
So I take a lambda.
So lambda transposed
times Ax minus b.
And the plus or the minus
sign here is not important.
I mean, you can choose
it because that will
determine the sign of lambda.
But either way, it's correct.
OK.
So we've introduced a function
that now depends on x and also
on lambda.
And there is a l--
and they multiply
each other in there.
And my point is that Lagrange
says, take the derivatives
with respect to x and lambda.
So that's the cool thing
that he's contributed.
He says if you only
create my function,
now you can take x derivative
and lambda derivative.
That will give you n
equation for the x--
from this one, from
the x derivative
and the m equation from
the lambda derivative.
It will be n plus m.
It will determine the
good x and the lambda.
But I'm saying that's all
true and all important.
But I'm saying that
the x and that pair x
lambda will be a saddle
point of this function.
This function has saddle
points, not a maximum.
OK.
Let's just take the derivatives
and see what we get.
So the derivatives with
respect to x, d by dx--
x is now a vector, so I
really should say the gradient
in the x direction.
I get Sx.
And here, the derivative with
respect to x, what that's--
that is A transpose lambda
because this is the dot product
of A transpose lambda with x.
You know, I've put
parentheses around it
and followed the transpose rule.
So that's the dot product of
A transpose lambda with x.
It's linear in x.
So it's derivative.
It's just A transpose lambda.
And that's zero.
And now I take the other
one, the lambda derivative.
The lambda derivative, this
doesn't depend on lambda.
The lambda derivative
is just Ax minus b.
It brings back the constraints.
So that's pretty simple.
It doesn't even
require much thought
because you just know the
constraints are coming back.
And of course, b should
be put over on this side
because it's a constant.
So there we see two--
a block.
We see an important, very
important class of problems.
And the matrix we're
seeing, we could
write this in block matrix
form, S minus A transpose.
Oh, I'm going to
change that into a plus
because I'm more
of a plus person.
OK.
A transpose and A, yeah, yeah.
When I took the derivative
with respect to lambda,
I didn't put the
minus sign in here.
And I didn't want to.
So let's make it a plus.
A and then there's
nothing there.
And the x, and the lambda,
and the zero, and the B.
That is the model of
a constrained minimum,
a minimum problem
with constraint.
It's the model because the
function here is quadratic
and the constraints are linear.
In Course 6, it's everywhere,
constantly appearing
as the simplest model.
OK.
And my point today is
just that the solution
x lambda, that total solution,
the x together with a lambda,
that that is a saddle point
of the Lagrangian function L.
It's a saddle point,
not a minimum.
It's sort of a minimum
in the x direction
because this is
positive definite.
As a function of
x, it's going up.
But somehow the
appearance of lambda
makes this matrix indefinite.
It starts positive definite,
but it has this A transpose A
and that 0.
It couldn't be p-- actually,
if I look at that matrix,
I see it's not
positive definite.
What do I see?
Why do I say that immediately?
When I look at that matrix, it's
not a positive definite matrix
because when I see
that 0 on the diagonal,
that shoots positive definite.
Couldn't be.
Take, as an example, S
equal 3, 1, and 1, 0.
Take that matrix.
Just random.
I made it 2 by 2 instead
of size m plus n.
Do you see?
Or how do I know that the
eigenvalues of that matrix, one
is plus and one is minus?
The determinant is negative.
So that tells me right away that
one is plus and one is minus.
Thanks.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
The determinant is negative.
And somehow here,
the determinate,
a similar calculation,
would produce A transpose A
or something with a minus
because I'm going this way.
Well, I could do
better than that.
But you saw the point.
That simple example of this
has eigenvalues of both signs.
Let me just quickly say,
and I'll put it in the notes
or in that chapter, I guess
that all this is coming--
is still 3.2.
That was originally 4.2.
And you will see it.
So what do I want to say?
I'd like to say that
that example is pretty
convincing to me that these KKT
matrices, if you talk to people
in optimization, that's
Karush, Kuhn, and Tucker,
three famous guys, and
these are the KKT conditions
that they derived
following Lagrange.
Right.
And my point is--
and this is a typical sort,
so it's an indefinite matrix.
I believe it has that if I
do an elimination, yeah, tell
me this.
This is a good
way to look at it.
Suppose I do elimination
on this one or on this one.
Well, suppose I do
elimination there.
What is the first pivot?
3.
Positive.
So now let me turn down to here.
What if I do elimination
on this block matrix?
Then I start up here.
And that first pivot is?
Positive again, right?
This S is a positive
definite matrix.
Don't forget.
In fact, the first n
pivots will all be positive
because the first
n pivots, you're
working away in this corner.
And if you're only
thinking about the first n,
this corner is size n by
n, then you don't even
see A. You're doing
some subtractions.
And I'll do those.
But the pivots
themselves are coming--
all coming from S. And
S is positive definite.
So we know that one of the tests
for a positive definite matrix
is all pivots are positive.
So I think all n of the first
pivots will be positive.
And when we use
them, let's just see
what happens when we use them.
So here is the KKT
matrix that I start with.
And what do I end up with?
Well, really, what I'm doing is
I'm multiplying that block row
by something to--
and subtracting to kill
that A. So these rows--
well, near enough.
Let me do block elimination.
Block elimination
is, like, easier.
I don't have to write down
all little tiny numbers.
So I just want to multiply
this row by something.
Tell me what.
And subtract from
this second row.
Suppose they're
numbers or letters.
I guess they are letters.
What do I multiply that
first row by and subtract?
Let's see.
If these were just little tiny
numbers, as like in 3, 1, 1, 0,
what do I multiply that row
by and subtract from this?
I multiply by A over S, right?
I do multiply by A over
S, which puts an A there.
Then I subtract.
So here I'll multiply by A
over S. But these are matrices,
so I multiply by S--
by AS inverse, right?
When I multiply by AS inverse
times this S, I get A.
And then I subtract.
And I get the 0.
And when I multiply by
this guy and subtract,
I get minus because I'm
subtracting this thing, minus
AS inverse, A transpose.
That was block elimination,
which just, in other words,
it's just--
you've learned about
2 by 2 matrices,
3x plus 4y equals 7 and stuff.
Now I'm just doing
it with blocks
instead of single numbers.
But you see, this produced
those positive pivots.
And what can you tell
me about that matrix?
What kind of-- what
can you tell me
about the signs or the
eigenvalues or whatever
of this matrix?
Suppose S was the identity.
What could you tell me
about minus AA transpose?
Minus AA transpose.
And my voice should
emphasize that minus.
It's that matrix there
is negative definite.
So all the next set of m
pivots that come from here
will all be negative.
So I get m or rather n, n
positive, and n negative
pivots.
And then I remember
that the pivots actually
have the same sign
as the eigenvalues.
That's just a beautiful fact.
We know that for
positive definite ones.
The eigenvalues
are all positive.
The pivots are all positive.
But it's even better than that.
If we have some mixture for
the signs of the pivots,
that tells us the signs
of the eigenvalues.
That's a really neat fact.
So I'll just write that down.
Plus and minus signs
of pivots give us
the plus and minus signs
of the eigenvalues.
So I've sneaked in a
nice matrix there that--
for symmetric matrices.
This is symmetric matrices.
OK.
That's what I wanted to say
about constraint and saddle
points coming from there.
And then I now want
to say something
about constraints and--
not constraints now.
I'm going to look at a second
source of saddle points.
So these will be saddles
from this remarkable function
that we know.
So I now have a
symmetric matrix S. Could
be even positive definite.
Usually, it is here.
Do you know what
the name for R is?
It's a ratio or a quotient.
It's named after somebody
starting with R. Who's that?
Rayleigh.
Right.
It's Rayleigh quotient.
And what is the largest
value, possible value
of the Rayleigh quotient?
We've seen this idea.
It is the maximum value
of that Rayleigh quotient,
of that ratio, is lambda max.
Right.
Lambda 1, the biggest one.
And the x that does
it is the eigenvector.
Right?
So max is lambda 1
and at x equal q1
because q1 transpose Sq
1, over transpose q1.
So I'm plugging in this winner.
And Sq1 is lambda 1q1.
Right?
It's the first eigenvector.
And so a lambda 1 comes out.
So I get lambda 1.
I know everything about that.
And what I know is if I put
in any x, what do I know?
If I put in any x whatever
and look at this number,
what do I know
about that number?
It's smaller than lambda 1.
Or it might hit lambda 1.
But it's not bigger.
That's why maxima are easy.
You put in any vector, and
you know what's happening.
You know, it doesn't--
it's not above the
max, obviously.
And what about the min?
That's equally
simple, of course.
It's at the bottom.
So what would be the
minimum of that Rayleigh--
of that quotient
if I was looking
for what eigenvector
and eigenvalue will
I find when I look at
the bottom of this?
I will find lambda
n, the last guy.
Lambda min.
At the winning x will
be its eigenvector.
And again, this stuff
will equal lambda n.
So that's easy.
I know that if I put
in any vector whatever,
just choose any
vector in dimensions
and compute r of x, what do
I now also know about our--
that R of that vector?
It's greater than lambda n.
Below the max, above the min.
Now what about
the other lambdas?
Well, the point is that
those are saddle points.
The beautiful thing about
this Rayleigh quotient
is its derivative equals 0
right at the saddle point--
at the eigenvectors.
And its value at the
eigenvectors is the eigenvalue.
You see what I'm saying?
I have lambda 1 here, a
max, lambda n here, a min.
And in between I have a
bunch of other lambdas,
which are saddle points.
And if I put an x into r of x
and look to see what happens,
I have no idea whether I'm
on this side, below it,
or this side, above lambda i.
So the saddle points
are more difficult
and take a little more patience.
So that's the other
source of saddle points.
Let me just emphasize
again what I'm saying.
At lambda at x equal qk,
I have some number the--
r of x has some number
of positive eigenvalues
and some number of negative
ones for the things
above and below qk.
OK.
I've run out of
time to follow up
on the saddle
point part of the--
on the details of this picture.
That will be on the notes.
And I might come back to it at
the very start of next time.
Before that, you will
have the lab number three.
And then I think we should
discuss it because I
haven't done this lab.
It's intended to give you
some feeling for overfitting
and also intended to give
you a little introduction
to deep learning.
And so I'll get it to you, and
we can talk about it Wednesday.
And again, it won't be due
until the Wednesday after break.
OK.
Thanks.
So I'll see you Wednesday.